space is a truly mysterious and
attractive place but at the same time it
is filled with some grave threats and
dangers
extreme temperatures lethal radiation
and a harsh environment are a threat to
any living being that would dare leave
its native planet but even against this
generally unfriendly background there
are still especially dangerous and scary
places that particularly stand out
let's check out the most horrifying ones
earlier in one of our previous videos we
have already taken a look at some
terrifying and lethally dangerous worlds
discovered in the vast expanses of space
with some of them extremely hot others
are located close to insanely powerful
sources of radiation and yet other ones
are peculiar for some bizarre features
on their surfaces
however we haven't quite exhausted our
list of the most horrifying planets and
now it's time to see some more
our first stop is 202 light years away
from the earth destination k2-141
an orange dwarf
its mass is roughly 0.7 that of the sun
and its radius measures 68 that of our
host star
with these parameters almost perfectly
proportional the star's temperature
reaches 4
600 kelvin
which is about 20 percent less than that
of the sun
and now to the planet in question
just .007 astronomical units away from
its star there lies a really bizarre
world designation k2-141b
this rocky exoplanet is five times as
massive as the earth with its radius 1.5
times as big as that of our earth
all this gives us grounds to assume that
the gravity on the planet's surface is
at least twice as strong as that on our
planet the heavy metallic core meanwhile
accounts for 20 to 50 percent of the
planet's overall mass it takes the
celestial body about six and a half
hours to complete a full orbit around
its parent star being extremely close it
is tidally locked to it that is it faces
the star with one on the same side at
all times
observations show that the temperature
on the planet's dayside reaches
3207 kelvin or 3000 degrees celsius
this is enough not only to melt most
trucks and metals but also to
effectively evaporate them
the day side of the planet is assumed to
be covered with a lava ocean that never
ceases to boil
the atmosphere is thought to be rather
exotic made up of steams of heavy metals
and silicates
by contrast the planet's night side is
incredibly freezing according to
estimates the temperature of most of its
area is tens of times lower than that on
the day side and on balance its values
are supposed to be sub-zero
mathematical modelling shows that this
sharp temperature contrast gives rise to
exceptionally strong winds whose speed
reaches 1.75 kilometers per second
this is roughly 5 times the speed of
sound which means that the surface of
k2-141b
is continuously shaken by exceptionally
powerful deafening rumbling
it is assumed that on reaching the night
side atmospheric streams condense and
precipitate on its surface in the form
of fiery rain
this forms lava rivers and eventually
the smelt and metal makes its way back
into the magma ocean to evaporate again
later on and to continue this incredible
fiery circulation
however this infernal cycle affects only
a relatively small part of the planet's
night side the thing is that masses of
evaporated elements from the dayside
simply don't make it to the main part of
the night side and precipitate somewhere
on the border that is why the central
part of the night side is likely to be a
freezing desert bound with layers of
solid rocks
remarkably k2-141b
is far from being the hottest planet
that we know of
for example there is an object referred
to as celt 9b
lying
670 light years away from the earth
its surface is as hot as
4600 kelvin which is approximately
4330 degrees celsius
just to compare the outer layers of
almost all red dwarfs for example are
much cooler
which means that in terms of temperature
this exoplanet is quite a match to stars
its parent star designation celt9 is of
a whitish blue colour and has a mass 2.6
times that of the sun
as for its diameter it is 2.3 times that
of our star
the surface temperature of count9 is
rather high at approximately 10
107 kelvin or a staggering
9900 degrees celsius
this largely accounts for the extreme
conditions on count 9b which lies quite
close by
just
.035 astronomical units away from its
parent star the planet completes a full
orbit around its system's center roughly
every one and a half days
celt 9b is a hot gas giant compared to
jupiter
its mass is 2.8 times as big and its
radius measures roughly twice as much as
that of the largest planet in our system
based on today's notions about the
composition of this type of planets the
inner part of count9b's atmosphere is
supposed to be even hotter
estimates allow for this value to reach
as much as 11 000 kelvin on account of
heavy metal ionization
with this figure so exceptionally big it
appears that the planet's atmosphere
should contain vaporized iron and
titanium alongside the elements we're
used to in an atmosphere's composition
such as hydrogen or helium
its close proximity to the parent star
and the extremely high temperature cause
the planet to gradually lose its
atmosphere
by and by powerful stellar wind blows it
off into space
which is why the object is shrouded in a
cloud of rarefied gas
this material will eventually be
attracted and absorbed by the star
interestingly according to some
estimates the exoplanet loses up to 68
earth masses every billion years
theoretically in a long while celt 9b
may well get stripped of all of its
atmosphere and transform itself into a
thonian planet
however its parent star is likely to hit
the final stage of its life cycle long
before that swallowing up and destroying
all the celestial objects within its
reach
the space objects we have just looked at
are a living proof as aware of the fact
that stars can destroy the planets close
to them and not just warm them up but
incidentally there are celestial objects
out there in the universe that have
experienced their parent star's wrath in
full measure
one of such objects lies 4500
light years away from the earth in the
environs of a small star designation
v391 pegasi
now the star is a white dwarf whose mass
is twice as little as that of the sun
and whose radius is approximately 23
percent that of our parent star the
temperature of the celestial object is
unbelievably high at almost 30 000
kelvin all thermonuclear reactions in
its interior would have run their course
a long while ago up ahead are hundreds
of billions of years of slow cooling
with the white dwarf eventually
transforming into a black one
the planet we will look at referred to
as v391 pegasi b is in this ordinary
star's environs its slot is
exceptionally amazing according to
mathematical modelling the planet not
only survived its progenitor star
shedding its outer layers but actually
found itself almost within the star for
some time it is assumed that when the
system's star v391 pegasi transformed
into a red giant its outer layers
extremely rarified by then were almost
brushing the planet's orbit their
density became dozens of times lower
than the atmospheric air were used to
which means that the celestial objects
devoured by the dying star remained
whole for a while and didn't get
destroyed at once
it goes without saying that they would
have been losing their speed and dropped
into the star's hotter and denser layers
still
v391 pegasi shed its outer layers sooner
than v391 pegasi b melted and ceased to
exist as a whole object at the moment
the exoplanet appears to be a gas giant
three times as massive as jupiter its
orbit passes 1.7 astronomical units away
from its parent star and it takes the
planet approximately
1170 earth days to complete a full orbit
around its system center it is still not
entirely clear how this astronomical
body managed to preserve such a big mass
after its collision with the scorching
hot layers of the star their influence
was supposed to have destroyed the
object's atmosphere completely
however there is no doubt that the host
star's collapse brought about some
dramatic changes both in terms of the
exoplanet's orbit and its parameters
that is why it is hardly possible for us
to ever find out what v391 pegasi b was
like before immersing in a sea of raging
plasma
space expenses conceal uncountable
astronomical objects with the most
bizarre properties
some of them are almost totally
invisible through regular telescopes but
can be detected by looking at radio
wavelengths when exploring space
an example of such like celestial
objects
is pulsars
neutron stars spinning on their axis at
a mind-boggling speed
these objects spectra are peculiar for
exceptionally fast and regular
pulsations that is why it is quite easy
to detect another celestial body
transiting between a radiation source
like that and an observer on the earth
this is precisely the way our next
object of interest was discovered
but first we'll be looking at a pulsar
which lies around 4 000 light years away
from the earth this neutron star boasts
quite a long name here it is on the
screen and now let's check out its
remarkable features the pulsar's
diameter is just a measly 20 kilometers
and its mass is approximately 1.4 that
of the sun the object spins at an
incredible rate with roughly 10 000
rotations a minute while continuously
emitting powerful electromagnetic
radiation impulses
now the surface of the exoplanet our
next object of interest is continuously
exposed to these waves of lethal
radiation which makes it a hostile and
forbidding place
it takes this planet just two hours to
complete a full orbit around its
system's center and the distance to the
pulsar is smaller than the sun's radius
just six hundred thousand kilometers or
0.004 astronomical units
incidentally the celestial body's
surface is bound by eternal code in
space as its parents start just barely
emits thermal energy the object's mass
is around 330 that of the earth while
its radius is four times that of our
planet
this makes gravity on its surface as
much as 20 times stronger than on the
earth
estimates show the planet's average
density to be about 23 grams per cubic
centimeter which is more than most
chemical compounds we know
the planet is thought to be made up for
the most part of crystallized carbon
under a lot of pressure
besides the object's upper layers
contain some oxygen which is probably
chemically bound with carbon
it is highly doubtful that a celestial
body located so close to a star could
possibly have survived a supernova event
it is more realistic to assume that the
exoplanet formed after the progenitor
star had come to the end of its life
cycle and had transformed itself into a
pulsar the exoplanet could be a piece of
debris left over from a white dwarf
whose material would have dispersed for
the most part
this makes classifying the exoplanet an
especially difficult task
still whatever it is
this world remains one of the most
dangerous and hostile ones lurking in
the depths of the cosmos
[Music]
the more we learn about space the more
we appreciate the incredible diversity
of astronomical objects perhaps there
are yet more new worlds to be discovered
literally just around the corner and
they may be so harsh that the lethal
planets we've just seen will feel like a
tropical paradise and comparison
either way any discovered celestial
object be it a star planet or even tiny
asteroid offers a chance of finding out
something new about countless mysteries
of the universe
and so if you wish to be in closer touch
with space and our channel we are happy
to announce a new opportunity especially
for this video we have prepared our
first nft set on the openc platform it
is three unique collectors cards of the
most horrifying exoplanets and there is
only one copy of each
also we present a collection animation
from the endings of our older videos
that probably only our earliest
subscribers would remember
the links and the instructions on how to
take part in the auction to purchase the
cards are in the description to this
video
future is in space
let's keep in touch
you